every summer audiences across the globe
are treated to the ultimate Beachbody
motivator American Ninja Warrior the
obstacle course competition that's taken
the world by storm the show has a long
and storied history and even super fans
might not realize just how far the show
has come since it first aired and just
how much goes into making it the epic
production it is today humble beginnings
early seasons of American Ninja Warrior
were very very different
it was initially known as American ninja
challenge a video submission series in
which contestants submitted videos of
themselves on obstacle courses with the
ultimate goal of being sent to compete
on a Japanese game show known as Ninja
Warrior in the States in those early
seasons contestants competed on a
qualifying course in Venice Beach then
the top 30 moved on to the finals where
they entered a boot camp that whittled
them down to just 10 Ninja finalists who
traveled to Japan to compete primetime
Journey American Ninja Warrior didn't
debut with a plum primetime spot on NBC
the show actually started out on g4 and
network within the company's cable group
but that channel doesn't exist anymore
but it provided a home for American
Ninja Warrior for its first three
increasingly popular seasons according
to host Matt Iseman
g4 went to NBC during the third season
and offered them the finale for free
saying quote just air it on NBC to tell
people g4 exists with little to no
promotion the obscure cable show ended
up winning the ratings for the night
leading to ninjas permanent Network
relocation in its fourth season take a
shot have you ever wanted to run the
American Ninja Warrior course but don't
think you're ready to apply
you're in luck the night before each
city's run a group of volunteers has
chosen for the chance to let producers
know if they need to make any
last-minute adjustments to the course
there's no money involved but they get
the chance to run the course and the
test their ninja skills without all the
pressure volunteers come from different
walks of life including prospective
contestants who sent in a tape but
didn't make the cut professional
stuntmen
and adjust regular folks as a core bonus
if you test out the course they let you
stay and watch the taping hidden
challenge up until season 5 American
Ninja Warrior contestants competed
during the day but since then filming
has taken place at night tell you things
in each city begin around a p.m. and go
into the wee hours of the morning with
some contestants doing their runs around
3 or 4 a.m.
even contestants who run earlier in the
night has to stick around that late if
they want to find out if they made it in
for the finals this is obviously pretty
taxing on contestants adding a whole new
layer of difficulty to an already
grueling show look at those forearms are
far Jacky I wish I had four model
cantaloupes in there beyond the course
being a great athlete doesn't guarantee
you a spot on American Ninja Warrior
well the show obviously puts quite a lot
of effort into finding contestants who
are able to compete there are a lot of
other factors that go into casting to
apply contestants have to submit a long
online questionnaire as well as a video
of themselves the video is where
contestants have to really let their
personalities shine that's when they try
to convince the casting directors that
they won't just be able to complete the
course
but that they'll also be fun to watch
while they do it
and now they're causing even tougher
back out of the court as with most
reality shows ninjas casting directors
are looking for contestants with
interesting stories who will inspire
viewers both on and off the course full
time Java many ninjas have to quit their
jobs if they want to get serious about
competing on the show especially as the
obstacles get more difficult because
being an elite level ninja is basically
like being a pro athlete contestants are
constantly finding new ways to make a
living based on the athleticism rather
than through traditional jobs this
includes doing commercials and making
appearances at gyms and other events
however some ninjas are still pushing
for more with many believing that the
future of the sports will come in
compensation for the athlete to appear
on the show to show us a $1,000,000
prize which only one person has won as
of the making of this video along with
smaller cash prizes for first second and
the third place in city finals courses
but there isn't compensation for all of
the athletes
[Applause]
some ninjas want the show to provide a
base compensation or for them to roll
back their stricter rules and athletes
growing sponsored clothing on the course
as the show continues to grow and as
competitive get more famous there will
likely have to be some changes to keep
the athletes coming back otherwise the
show's pool of potential contestants
could go extinct jagalchi reg thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all those cool stuff we know
you're not too